protesters thought guinea would quickly
return to civilian rule
when they backed a military coup against
president alfa conde last year
now they say they've been duped
set manifestation this protest is
revenge against this regime we thought
the coup was a change but no it's just a
change of facade i support the fndc i
support it in everything that it's doing
after taking power the military promised
a three-year transition back to civilian
rule
protesters say that's too long
and the west african regional block
echoes agrees
i was in concrete with the president of
the commission of ecowas to make the
military junta understand the decision
of the summit of heads of state that the
transition cannot exceed 24 months
the national front for the defense of
the constitution or fndc was a coalition
of political parties and civil society
organizations founded in 2019.
it led a wave of protests opposing
conde's plan to change the constitution
and run for a third term
now it's demonstrating against the
military
the consensus that developed around the
coup in september of 2021 is no longer
there that civil society and opposition
parties
are determined to have a say
and if the junta doesn't open up
a more inclusive more consultative more
transparent transition process then we
could be in real trouble in guinea
conakry
the military hunter has banned protests
but these demonstrators aren't listening
barbara angopa al jazeera